input-output is brought to you by the HP
printing pay back guarantee will cut
your printing costs or will cut you a
check some companies have already saved
up to thirty percent in overall printing
costs visit HP com / guarantee to start
saving
hi I'm Peter Hopkins president and
co-founder of big thing calm is my
pleasure today to welcome the chairman
and CEO of Kaiser Permanente George
Halverson for a special interview to
discuss the state of American healthcare
and its future it is a particular
pleasure to have George here because of
the nature of Kaiser this is a company
that is the largest private insurer in
the world as over eight million members
and it is unique in the way that it
delivers care in this country because it
is a completely vertically integrated
provider which means that it not only
provides the insurance but it provides
the care it owns the hospital's it owns
the pharmacies it is managing all
aspects of the care of its patients with
kids which gives it a truly unique
perspective and so gives George a truly
unique perspective and and thus I'd like
to welcome you today George for a
conversation and welcome to happy
welcome here it's good to be here all
right so let's start with the issue that
you've identified cost is really one of
the most important in the health care
debate and one of the least understood
if I'm quoting you correctly you've said
that the health care debate in this
country isn't one that isn't where of
the real cost of our health care and is
importantly the price differential that
exists between other industrialized
countries and the u.s. is not an
informed debate why haven't we focused
on the price differential you know it's
fascinating because we're having debate
about the affordability of healthcare in
America and the vast majority of the
people who are in the debate have no
sense whatsoever that we actually pay
more for health care in this country by
the piece than anywhere in the world I
in my books are right about the fact
that we pay more by the piece more by
the package or by the patient more by
the procedure movie Reinhart wrote an
article five years ago saying it's the
price of stupid a good article in yet
the debate completely and totally
ignores that point and when you look at
the price
differences between us and the other
countries we pay three times as much for
drugs we pay twice as much for
technology every single country in
Europe spends less than a thousand
dollars a day for hospital stays there's
not one state in the u.s. that charges
less than 3,000 so when you look at the
numbers just the straight unit price we
pay much more in the US and yet that
whole issue has not been discussed that
any level in the healthcare debate in
Washington we've dealt with other issues
and good issues may we need to fix
insurance in this country we need to
cover everyone and and we really can't
improve care to the level we need to for
the contrary until we ensure everyone
because we need everyone with coverage
and everyone in the database and we need
to fix care so that we can afford to
cover everyone but we also need to have
a sense of what the underlying unit
prices are and that part of the debate
has been completely off the radar screen
why do you think that is Ben I mean in
your book you identify five very clear
causes of this rise in prices you know
ranging from general inflation to new
technologies to perverse incentives why
have these major forces that have
actually caused the system to you know
potentially go off the rails why have
they gone so unheated thus far on the
cost side of the equation there's a lot
of uninformed debate remarkably
uninformed debate people have no sense
that chronic conditions drive 75% of the
health care costs people have heated
debate about one cost of one drug for
cancer care and when you put that drug
into perspective that's less than
one-tenth of one percent of the total
healthcare spend in America and yet
diabetics consume thirty two percent of
the cost of Medicare and we are
delivering care so in consistently in
this country that we're only getting
care right for diabetics about eight
percent of the time
so you've got a condition that's driving
thirty-two percent of the cost of
Medicare and we have an inconsistency
and care delivery and we're not getting
care right then you have another
condition that drives a fraction of a
percent and you have a heated debate I
think folks in policy level should be
informed by their actuaries and by their
caregivers simultaneously so that we can
take a look at what's really driving
healthcare costs in this country because
we're not going to fix the real issues
unless we actually understand the real
issues and then address the real issues
now we have a couple of slides that I
want to show one is comparing the cost
of a physician visit in this country to
other countries and it is just off the
charts you know can you perhaps
breakdown you know what is going on in
this country specifically that you would
see the u.s. you know so far outpace you
know germany spain france in that you
know just attending their their general
practitioner well it's literally an
issue that we have a different fee
schedule in the u.s. that fee schedule
in the u.s. tends to have a lot of
variation in canada if you deliver baby
you get paid 475 dollars that's it if
you deliver baby in paris you get paid
1050 dollars that's it in the u.s. if
you deliver baby get paid somewhere
between fifteen hundred and forty-five
hundred dollars well premium which is
what everybody pays to buy their health
care premium is the total cost of care
divided by the total number of people
who have coverage so if the total cost
of care goes up if you're paying 45
hundred dollars for a delivery you
obviously are going to have a much
higher premium than you would in canada
if he paid 475 so why can the costs go
up more in the u.s. because the
marketplace rewards cost increases in
the US and it does not reward cost
increases in the other countries now
let's isolate that what does it mean to
reward cost increases and why is that
violin
so many of the basic fundamental
principles of economics I mean in your
book which is a really tremendous book
health care will not reform itself you
identify a kind of almost another
dimension of economics under which our
health care system operates and you know
illustrate that here with this it
actually validates economic so the
organization's charge more because they
can and the reason they charge more is
because they get the money I mean it's
very very simple basic economics and
it's about pricing so in Canada the
doctors can't increase that price and
therefore they don't but if they could
they would there's no way in the world
that Canadian prices would voluntarily
be where they are today so health care
costs and Canada in total are about half
of healthcare costs in the US now it's
been said that this is because the
outcomes the total quality of care is
really detached as you say from from the
sort of unit pricing model that we've
got how have other countries been able
to bring the quality of outcomes better
into alignment they actually have it the
other countries don't do a very good job
on their chronic conditions they don't
do a very good job on their
follow-through they do a much better job
of primary care every citizen in the
other countries ends up with a primary
care doctor they're all private
physicians the Francis full private
physicians Netherlands are full of rival
physicians in fact you're waiting times
for an appointment to the Netherlands
are half the average waiting times in
the US because of many primary care
doctors and they have a good
infrastructure of primary care doctors
but they actually don't coordinate care
much better than we do relative to
asthma or diabetes and they're actually
working on that we've got people from
European countries visiting Kaiser all
the time
studying what we're doing and looking at
our care coordination and our linkages
in our team care trying to figure how
they can take that back and apply it in
their own countries the reason the costs
are lower is not because they do a
better job of coordinating that care
it's because they pay less for every
piece of carrot the prescription drug
costs in the u.s. typically are about
three times as high as the same drug in
Canada CT scans are double triple in the
u.s. what they are in in the European
countries so if you pay more I mean the
opportunity in the US the really big
opportunity is to do a better job
delivering great care what we need to do
is take the diabetics of this country
and deliver care for diabetics that is
so consistent and so dependable and so
high quality that we cut the number of
kidney failure Xin half we cut the
number of people go blind and have their
there's great opportunity there so I
think we really need a care improvement
agenda in America to make care better
and that's the great opportunity here
and the other countries the other
countries actually are complaining about
their cost trajectory they're running a
ten percent of the gdp and we're running
in 17.6 but they're still seeing the
cost of care going up because of
populations are getting older they're
prescribing more drugs they're doing
more tests all the same things are true
they just start from a lower base
because they pay lower unit price now I
want a key a slide that we have that
actually illustrates the point about the
cost of CT scans and gives yet another
example of how the differential is just
so incredible i also want to talk about
diabetics and other people with chronic
conditions because they really are at
the heart of this debate in your book
you identify some really compelling
statistics you know about actually I how
what segments of the the patient
population are consuming the total cost
of care can you lay out some of those
statistics and give people a sense that
of how much of our investment
care is really being concentrated on a
motive Lee small portion of population
well it's about first of all 75% of the
costs of care come from people with
chronic conditions about 80% come from
people with comorbidities so if multiple
conditions so we have a lot of people
who have asthma congestive heart failure
diabetes coronary artery disease and
those are the people who are encouraged
to the cost of health care we have a
very small number of people who are
occurring most of those costs so one
percent of the population is about
thirty-five percent of the cost five
percent population about fifty percent
ten percent of the populations eighty
percent of the cost so if we went to
that ten percent of the population or
eighty percent of the cost and did a
much better job of delivering care to
those people we could make a huge
difference in the cost of care in
America and we could also make care
better and that's the opportunity the
real opportunity is to make care better
by focusing on the people who really
need team care in delivering that care
and doing in a systematic way and the
best way of doing that is to have
computer support for your care the best
way of doing that is to have all of the
information about each of the patients
all the time so we need all information
about the patient's needs to be
available real time and the caregiver in
the exam room who is dealing with the
patient needs to understand all the
information in most of the time in the
United States because we are so
splintered relative to the care delivery
system doctors taking care of a patient
only know the prescriptions they've
written they only know the tests they've
taken they don't know other diagnoses
they don't know other treatments they
don't know other procedures and so
everything is chopped up into pieces and
when you chop it up into pieces and
deliver care piecemeal that's extremely
frustrating for the patient it's also
frustrating for the caregiver and it's
inadequate care and the only way you can
link that care is to get that data on a
computer you can't link it there's no
possible infrastructure you can imagine
of thousands of trucks driving around
town shuffling pieces of paper from
Doctor to doctor where you could end up
with kind of information coordination
you need you've got to get that
information into a computer and then you
need to have the doctor able to access
that information so for a given patient
they know what the next treatments need
to be and also so there could be care
plans about each patient right now the
care plans are also very siloed and
isolated so the doctor who is treating a
patient for allergies does not link up
with the oncologist who does not link up
with the internist who does not link up
with the cardiologist and so you end up
with these doctors each doing separate
care plans and there are people that
have 24 and 28 prescriptions that
they're taking with no coordination
between them and some of them counter
under Kate got creating danger actually
for the patient we just need a
systematic approach to care in this
country and we can do it we spent twice
as much money in care as anyplace else
in the world and we have a computer
infrastructure for every other aspect of
the economy there's no reason not to
apply systematic thinking programmatic
thinking in team-based thinking to cure
it should happen and if it doesn't
happen we're going to continue to have
the same kinds of outcomes that we have
now with twice as many people with
failed kidneys now talk to us about
kaisers experience because you say this
from actually a vantage point of having
been there yeah you know five years ago
Kaiser undertook a massive multi-billion
dollar access to actually institute
electronic medical records and develop
the coordination that you're describing
give us the history of that initiative
what was what brought Kaiser to that
that that turning point and you know
what was the thinking and and the
rationale behind it well Kaiser as you
said earlier is a vertically integrated
system so we have the largest private
medical group
in the world we have a hospital system
that we own and operate we own our own
labs and clinics and have all the pieces
of the care delivery system what we
didn't have was an integrated database
about all those patients so we also even
though we had integrated care delivery
and information silos didn't have the
connectivity didn't have real-time data
and we said if we're going to take this
very nice model which we're very fond of
of vertically integrated care system if
we're going to optimize this model we're
really going to perfect it we need
information we have to have the data we
have to have all of the data pieces
available in real time to the doctor in
the exam room so it went down that path
and we said we're going to computerize
the entire database and we did and so
right now doctors in Kaiser Permanente
clinics see no paper totally electronic
they get all of information about the
patients electronically and they have
the information in real time if they
want to do a consult with another Kaiser
physician they can do that
electronically so you can actually have
the patient the doctor and the
specialist hooked up in a virtual model
to do the consults because the data
flows from site to site seamlessly and
that makes a big difference in care
delivery so we took that model and put
it at first in Colorado we took the data
and extracted from the computer system
once we had all the patients in the Mac
record we created care plans for all the
patients with heart conditions and made
sure that we delivered on the care plan
so that it was a team of primary care
doctor cardiologists pharmacists nurses
receptionist I mean full care team
relating to the patient with care plans
for each patient that we tracked through
the computer supported through the
computer and reminded people of the next
thing to do through the computer and we
cut the death rate from both major forms
of heart disease by seventy-three
percent in two years so it's a cut in
the death rate
by getting care right no no science no
no drugs no new procedures no no
surgeries just consistency absolute
consistency of care delivery and if a
patient didn't fill a prescription and
right now a doctor writes prescription
patient walks out with a prescription
you have no idea whether or not that
patient is filling that prescription and
if they do fill it you have no idea if
they've refilled it and so the number of
prescriptions that don't get refilled in
this country is huge it's a majority of
chronic here prescriptions don't get
refilled in our model what happens is
the patient doesn't refill the
prescription it's our pharmacy system
bell goes off the primary care doctor is
notified and the care team goes into
gear and then typically a pharmacist
will sit down talk to the patient and
say that particular drug you didn't
refill it will actually force the doctor
will then the pharmacist but that drug
didn't work for you here's two other
drugs that do the same thing let's try
one of these and so we end up with a
care team approach and followed drug
developed drug in the consistency by
creating consistency creating Hall up
and crew compliance with the care
patterns we've cut the death rate and
we've done a similar thing and cutting
broken bones we've created the same kind
of consistency teams of caregivers and
had a reduction in broken bones of
thirty-seven percent now if you think
about that that's a huge reduction it
makes sense for us because we're prepaid
we get a premium take care of the
patient because we get a premium take
care of the patient we don't have to
build by the piece for each piece of
care we're about the total package of
care and if we had been a
fee-for-service hospital system in lost
thirty seven percent of our patient
admissions for broken bones you'd have a
committee up in arms and alarmed and
wondering how do you fill that space for
us it's about the patient it's not about
the opportunity to bill for a hospital
admission because we're pre paid for the
entire amount now have a couple
questions that emerged from that the
first is how do you make sense of the
ethics of your colleagues outside you
know who have the standard models where
they are you know putative ly working
for the betterment of their patients and
then would have such a committee to
explore why in excess of care is no
longer taking place how can those two
things coexist in the minds of so many
of the providers in this country well
there aren't any providers out there
that are doing deliberately doing bad
care but if you are not within Kaiser
Permanente in your primary care doctor
you don't have a relationship with an
orthopaedic support team you don't have
a relationship with a nurse practitioner
who's working with a patient you don't
have a database about the patient to
identify that this patient is high risk
of having broken bones so they don't
have the pieces may one of the reasons I
say health care will not reform itself
in the book is that health care doesn't
have the toolkit to actually achieve
reform so if you get two doctors three
doctors who want to coordinate care for
patient in America right now it's
actually very hard there's no mechanism
there's no data flow there's no
interchange there's even privacy
barriers that HIPAA sorts of things that
keep the doctors from sharing
information with each other so when you
want to share information and do a
better job of delivering care for a
patient instead of facilitating that we
actually create barriers to it and then
we create functional barriers and legal
barriers and that's not good that's not
good for the patient because the
patients need team care in best care but
there are other issues like the hospital
safety is a huge example if you look at
the infection rates in hospital
California we looked at some numbers a
while ago two percent of the patients in
California hospitals renting up of
sepsis okay twenty-three percent of the
deaths were from patients with sepsis
now that's one out of five patients who
are dying if you do the right job up
front if you identify the people
immediately if you intervene immediately
if you have a team of caregivers ready
to jump on each sepsis case and prevent
it and roll a condition back you can cut
the sepsis 2's in half I think about
that as a patient if you're going in as
a patient do you want to be in a setting
that has twice as many people dying of
sepsis or do you want to be in a setting
that they have half as many people dying
of sepsis hospitals have no financial
incentive right now in this country to
vent the sepsis deaths and the sepsis
cases are huge bills and so there's a
lot of revenue that flows from those
cases and nobody would ever deliberately
go down that path and no hospital of
America would ever deliberately create
sepsis but what we need is an agenda
that cuts those deaths in half we really
need that in this country and we need to
get all the hospitals on board with that
agenda we need to get all of the major
buyers on board with that agenda because
we need to make Hospital safer in this
country and have better outcomes and in
the process will end up reducing costs
there was a study that came out about
two weeks ago it was a fascinating study
because they analyzed each of several
thousand hospitals and they analyzed the
hospital's based on their process and
they rated them from one star which was
very weak internal process to five stars
which was very solid internal process to
in continuous improvement tracking care
and then doing follow-up care so they
rated them based on process then they
went back and looked at what's the
difference in survival rate from once
their hospital till five star hospital
and it was amazing if you went to a
five-star hospital instead of a
three-star hospital you were fifty two
percent less likely to die of anything
you were admitted for anything here a
bit afore and if you went to a one-star
hospital you were seventy-nine percent
more likely to die then if you want to
fight their hospital that's in the
United States of America today ratings
though the consumers could have in front
of it we should have that but also we
should have an agenda in this country to
have nothing but five-star hospitals we
spend way too much money we spent twice
as much money as anyone in the world on
health care we should have nothing but
five-star hospitals and to do that we
have to think systematically we have to
have the people in the hospital thinking
systematically about best care we have
to have each hospital creating an agenda
that puts in place the systematic
thinking and the team training and doing
all the right things for the patients to
make sure there's things as simple as
that everyone washes their hands while
they're there moving between patients
and treating patients but some basic
stuff and making sure that there are
response teams with the number of
hospitals in America who don't even
train people in code blue crash teams is
stunning I mean if you think about it
you're in the hospital you're about to
die Hospital you know code blue you know
you watch all the TV shows you know what
it looks like and they keep inventing
that over and over again on the spot if
you invent code blue on the spot with
whoever happens to be there at the time
that's not anywhere near as good a
process is if you have drilled and
rehearsed and choreographed and you knew
the code blue means you got to get a
doctor in the room now and you've got
again a nurse who understands crisis in
the room right now and you've got a if
you if you do a code blue that's based
on getting the right people there at the
right time and doing the right things to
save a lot of lives and if you have a
code blue that's based on
code blues anybody ever you know I mean
the what's sad is the TV shows about the
people in kind of inventing this on the
fly and are more accurate then you as a
patient should want them to be so the
best hospitals and the best systems are
going to be doing things systematically
and if you're at a hospital ask them how
many code blue rehearsals they've done
and did they do simulations we have
actually at Kaiser Permanente we have
mannequins mannequins that have heart
attacks have strokes give birth whatever
and we actually drill with the
mannequins and so our people can instead
of drilling on live patients they can
have a stroke crisis and deal with it
with a dummy that actually responds well
11 little interesting thing you might
find interesting I bet on a fascinating
was that when the mannequins a couple
years ago they programmed them to stop
dying because caregivers go into
caregiving professions because they're
caring people and some of the people on
the training if they lost a mannequin
would actually have emotional problems
and some some folks actually would take
that experience out and feel really bad
about it because they're really nice
people and it was a bad thing so they
now go into kind of a comatose situation
and don't go all the way to demise but
every hospital in America should be
training with mannequins every hospital
in America should be making sure the
sepsis patients get an immediate
response so now but what you've just
described seems to transcend just the
technology it's the changing of
behaviors and you're describing a kind
of an abs
the procedure in absence of protocol
across America American hospitals how
did you confront that a Kaiser because
it's often said that one of the big
obstacles is just getting healthcare
providers to do things differently and
you know as you say in the book you know
technology cannot do that it you know
it's beyond that how did you guys
approach creating a different strategy
for help one of the things we did was we
started collecting data and before we
collected data about infection rates and
hospitals we were assuming that all of
our hospitals were doing really well
because everyone knows the right things
to do and everybody felt we were doing
things really well and if you ask the
people running each of our hospitals put
their hand on the lie detector and take
a test on how well they're doing they
all would have passed and then we
collected the data and discovered that
some weren't doing exceptionally well
and some were not doing well at all and
then we started tracking and in
providing internal feedback and the rest
of the world needs to be doing that as
well that you need a database in that's
part of the issue Don Berwick from the
Institute for Healthcare Improvement ihi
dr. Berwick has been going around to
hospitals all over the country and
helping them improve process and he did
a program a couple hundred couple of
years ago called a hundred thousand Life
campaign and he identified a couple of
very basic process improvement hospitals
could make and if they made them they
would save hundred thousand lives in
America and he's brilliant and if ever
been known that easy bro guy so he went
out did his campaign and succeeded and
saved way more than hundred thousand
lives but the most important thing
wasn't that just that he got hospitals
to start doing process improvement a ten
two thousand lives the important thing
was the same learning they put in place
to save the hundred thousand lives is
now in place and can be used for other
hospital improvement processes so it
created a template it created at the
beginning of a new culture
because the old culture was everything
is locally invented everything is done
by each care site on its own and your
job is to be kind of the Lone Ranger
kind of a cowboy and I mean I've seen
issues like many hospitals in the
country when nurses change shifts the
nurses going out after brief a nurse is
coming in that is so non-standardized in
most settings that it's often not even
standardized some shift the shift so the
nurse who does a doing lunch chef will
do it differently at the end of the
shift it does it differently at the end
of the show and it varies from Florida
floor and Department of department and
so many of the information errors to
take place in hospitals in a lot of them
take place take place at the change of
shift so one of the things that we
discovered a couple years ago was if we
standardize that process if we create a
single process that make sure all of the
right information is there and it's
shared in the right way we actually
added KP took the process time for 47
minutes per shift down to 16 minutes in
just about eliminated errors just by
systematizing in hospitals all over
America some hospitals are saying her a
lovely wonderful i doing another's are
saying no no no no we will do it our way
stay out of our world don't don't preach
to us now we're going to do our own way
and as a patient that's scary as a
patient it's quite frightening to know
that you get that kind of inconsistency
happening in hospitals and they're such
a variation in terms of safety now as
you went on the under took the massive
task of coordinating your rather large
scale health care infrastructure what
were some of the unforeseen issues the
challenges that you faced and
undertaking that these avi both the
providers but also just the
you know getting the technology to work
we actually didn't have as many
surprises in our shop as sunlight partly
because we started with a vertically
integrated system and we started with
some sharing of records and we started
with some electronics and so within
Kaiser Permanente the process I actually
went amazingly well and very quickly but
one of the things we started with was
what we call the collaborative build so
we had a collaborative bill we brought
together medical leaders from all over
the country and we had them spend a
couple of weeks sitting down talking
about what do we want this system to do
in the end what should the pieces be how
should and what are the the
functionality issues what do we want to
achieve with this in and that group
taught each other what it wanted to
achieve but it also created a common
vision for where we were going so the
collaborative build actually drove the
whole process in a very good way most
hospital systems that have gone down
that path and even most countries Great
Britain has been trying to do an
electronic medical record they started
about the same time we did they spend at
least twice as much money and they still
don't have a system that's functioning
at the level that you would like it to
function and one of the reasons is they
skipped that front end they skipped the
clever to built they skipped a doctor
buy-in and so they didn't have a bunch
of very smart doctor say here's what we
can do in Great Britain to make care
better so what they did was they had a
system built by systems people exactly
yeah and so they don't have what so by
having a collaborative build up at the
front end and then we also said that the
system is going to be basically vanilla
upfront so we're going to the same
definitions of everything and the same
coding and we're not going to vary
coding from site to site in several
other hospital systems that have tried
to do electronic medical records have
allowed for all kinds of variation site
to site by the time you're done you
don't have the system that's
interoperable and when you make changes
in it
we have some variations I decide because
if somebody wants to put the name first
or the age first I mean there are some
things you can do differently on the
screen but everybody has their name and
everybody has a rage and everybody has a
diagnosis we use the same coding
everywhere and so the there's a
standardization of the the basic
information that was really important
and there are some places that didn't do
that as well so if you don't have a
standard data sad if you don't have to
enter process and you don't have buying
at the beginning and then you put out
electronic medical record and your
they're in trouble the other thing that
we did and this was hugely important is
we deliver care for a living so we knew
that just having the data wasn't enough
that we had to have the data but then we
had to have systems that extract of the
data the reach into the computer pull
the data out and for a given doctor say
for your panel of 2,000 patients here
are the six people that most need
attention and here's the attention they
need that type of thing and we have been
experimenting so we've got eight
different versions of that which is a
good thing because we're doing it a
little differently in Hawaii than we're
doing at Portland we're doing it
differently in Denver and we're learning
from ourselves be in if there would have
been a single perfect template somewhere
for that extract process we would have
gone there there isn't so we're learning
that as we go so we're building the
pieces of it and now we're sitting down
comparing how well does what we're doing
at Portland do compared to what we're
doing in Hawaii and what can we learn
from Hawaii that will transfer to
Washington DC it's a very exciting
process we got a lot of very very bright
people right now who are highly
energized and very excited about the the
opportunity to do this work and I've
heard several people describe it as
being like the internet when the
internet came into being people had a
few generic ideas about they might do
with it and then those ideas expanded
and expanded and expanded and and now
there's a vast expansion
of all the kinds of things you can do
for connectivity and we're doing the
same thing we're we're expanding as well
we're also redefining the patient
experience because the patients can not
only get their medical record
electronically so each of our patients
can get their barrel medical record when
they when they want it but the other
thing that that's fascinating about they
you can also even travel with it if you
want to put it on a little drive and
take it along you can get it along but
the interesting thing is what patients
really like a lot is he visits really
like electronic visits in three years
ago and we introduced electronic visits
we had 1 million patients first year
second year 3 million this year 6
million Eve isn't swell have six million
he visits this year and I think there's
a good chance it will go to 12 I think
we're on the exponential growth in the
reasons pointers because the patients
absolutely love it now I'm curious
you've been doing this at a moment where
technology is just changing itself as
warp speed you began this process over
five years ago how has the technology
changed over the last five or ten years
as Kaiser has you know conceived of and
implemented this process and and how has
that you know changed your outlook there
are several things we're doing that are
we have a place called the Garfield
Center in the Garfield center looks very
California looks like a big film studio
and we have all kinds of mock hospital
beds of homes clinical offices hold it
we sat down and we model in the Garfield
Center what the care delivery
functionality of the future should look
like so we've got connectivity when
you're talking about the reaching out
five years ago the ability to reach in
someone's home and do home monitoring
home connectivity home visits was
relatively light it's a much much much
more robust technology now and it's
going to be much more
in the future so we've got smart people
working with those issues trying to
figure out what's the next generation of
connectivity what's the next generation
of data flow at the technical level of
gut issues about data storage on the
back end and those types of things but
those are pretty fundamental to anybody
that runs a lot of data but on the front
end we're trying to stay focused on the
patient and the care delivery and figure
out what's the next level of interactive
technology and what are we what should
we be doing with patients to influence
behavior one of our pilot said that
actually worked really well was just a
simple pilot that took a bunch of
patients who wanted to lose weight and
had a computer send them reminder emails
two or three times a day to not eat to
not snack whatever their particular
issue was they actually got emails from
us reminding them and the people who
were getting those reminders over a few
months lost about 15 pounds I mean it's
that's a very kind of low tech high tech
type of thing but it's the kind of thing
that you don't do up front then you
start thinking about what kind of
connectivity can we have and how can we
use this equipment and a in an
interesting way and again we've got some
very smart people who are doing the
other thing that's really fun is the
research because we can do research and
nobody else can do so we went back and
took a look at patient data that we had
from 35 years ago and we still have the
patience because we because of who we
are we keep patients for a very long
time so we have 35 years of data and we
identified that if you had high
cholesterol in your 40s and you had a
certain weight issue you were three
hundred and sixty percent more likely to
have Alzheimer's in your section three
hundred sixty percent more likely we
identified which population we went back
we could take the current database
across a broad population and then sort
back into the characteristics of those
people 30 years ago and identify several
very important things about them
and in one of them was that and this is
very scary for those of us who carry too
much weight and had high cholesterol in
our 40s the likelihood of Alzheimer's is
way way up which also might explain why
there are so many more cases of
Alzheimer's now than they used to be
because I mean it's those kinds of
things so we're taking that kind of
research and learning things that we
couldn't have learned without large
amounts of data that that's current
about patients and longitudinal data now
we're adding to that DNA so we're
collecting DNA samples and we will have
the biggest private DNA database in the
world in a very short time we'll have
about 400,000 people who have
voluntarily put their DNA into our
database by the end of this next year so
a 400,000 people at the end of the year
and we'll have all the DNA and we'll run
the profiles and we will then have the
medical profiles so we'll be able to
identify all kinds of things that the
discovery that's going to come out of
that process I think is there will thing
be things that we don't even suspect
right now I mean who would have who to
fat the cholesterol and Alzheimer's had
a direct relationship I mean the things
that will learn with the DNA database is
really exciting so our researchers right
now are feeling very good about kind of
things are going to be doing now I want
to put up a couple of slides that I
think may suggest how all of this
revolution within Kaiser has affected
you know its success in treating
patients US News just released its
2009-2010 rankings of the best health
care plans both for general private
health care as well as Medicare and
Medicaid and Kaiser ranked number one in
Medicare and Medicaid do you see this
what you've just described all of these
efforts as we rounding to that outcome
that
that honor I think when you look at that
on or and you look at the fact that when
you look at the heat asst reports the
quality reports for health care where
they talk about things like follow up on
the Frollo G cases we now lead the
country in about 11 categories and the
reason we lead the country in about 11
categories in five years ago we led the
country in one or two get ours is
because we have the database and we have
the system that so that we can do the
kind of follow up that we need to do so
on a number of conditions would not only
lead the country but we're number one in
each of our geographic areas as well so
we're number one nationally number one
locally and a whole number of areas that
would not be true if we didn't have a
tool kit that we have now takes the tool
kit then it takes the people it takes a
culture of continuous improvement and
then it takes people using the data
because just you know putting it out
there isn't sufficient it has to be the
total effort but people can work really
hard and not get to be number one if you
don't have the tools necessary to get
the number one so yes I would definitely
say that the things we put in place and
helped us you painted a pretty
extraordinary vision of what could be
it's take it a step farther how if we
are able to scale this approach
nationally what do you envision what is
what what could this do this revolution
in information technology what could it
do to the American healthcare system
what are we talking about in in real
examples in real ideas well I think we
need a database for the entire country
that helps us track how well we're doing
in the major areas where we're not
performing well but I think we need to
do it sort of step by step and
conditioned by condition so take as my
asthma is the fastest growing condition
among kids it's number one killer it's
the number one expense item
it's a horrible condition when kids have
asthma attacks one of my sons had
multiple asthma tax years ago and you
know when they're almost dying because
they're going through the misery they're
going through that's a very very
traumatic everybody and sometimes we do
diam is it's all bad and when you look
at the country how well we're doing in
asthma care the most recent ran study
showed that we're getting it right forty
seven percent of the time so
fastest-growing condition horrible
condition we're only getting around
forty seven percent of the time we
should fix that if we covered every kid
in America which is why we need
universal coverage if we covered every
kid in America that's a starter because
then they can get the inhaler and then
they can get the medication but in
addition to that covering them is not
enough in addition to that we need to
have information about every kid with
asthma we need to know who they are and
then we need something tracking whether
or not those kids are getting the
appropriate care whether or not they
refill in the prescription like I talked
about earlier with the heart patient we
need to know if those inhalers are being
refilled and if they're not when you'd
intervene and what we really need to
know is if the kid has a crisis if they
have a asthma attack and they're in the
emergency room we need to know that that
crisis happened and then that needs to
trigger an intervention so that somebody
can do something meaningful to make it
better and in the current unconnected
system nobody knows no one has a clue so
the person has the asthma attack and the
hospital has an information for the
hospital has no one to give it to and
they have no mechanism to give it
through and so what you end up with is a
kid having another attack another attack
another attack some die and then some
crippled and debilitated and certainly
demoralized and then it's a bad
condition we could easily say as a
country we're going to focus on that
we're going to fix that we're going to
make that better and we're going to use
universal coverage and the new database
to do that so that's what we need to do
as a country and if we fix a few things
if we fix congestive heart failure you
know we can cut to congestive heart
failure admissions for Americans and
I have an absolute consistent follow-up
care but we're not going to do that
until everybody has coverage and until
there's a care coordination process
embedded in the coverage but there's no
reason not to do that and we will save a
lot of money for the country and will
save a lot of misery and agony and
terror for the people involved if we do
that this is a good moment to segue to
some questions that have been submitted
by the audience as they've been watching
this and the first is about you know
technology this is from twitter username
at harry mccracken tech is a huge part
of fixing health care so why does it
seem so rarely seem to be a part of the
debate you know why are we not why is
this not front and center why is this
not a part of every single discussion
because nobody knows what to do with the
technology people don't have a sense of
how to use I just talked about how to
use for asthma care but when when people
talk about technology what they
generally say in this very generic way
almost magical thinking let's put all
the data on a computer and then care
will get better well that doesn't work
care doesn't get better when you put it
on the computer then you have to do
something with the data and somebody has
to be accountable for doing that and so
you have to create a data infrastructure
but then you have to create an
accountability and then you have to
create the mechanisms and if all you do
is put it on the computer that's not
enough and then people know that but
what people talk about a front is let's
get all the data on the computer so if
an individual doctor says I'm getting a
lot of pressure due to computerize my
office and they go down that path and
they invest all the money to computerize
their office and then when they're done
instead of having a paper file with
information about you as a patient they
have an electronic file with information
about you as a patient it's the same
information it hasn't expanded it hasn't
gotten better it hasn't gotten
interactive it's just electronic in
electronic doesn't care anything what
cures things is if that database is then
connected to another database and you
other every other doctor you have is in
the database and then there's team care
that can come out of that and also more
informed care but the agenda is up to
now for American healthcare because the
doctors are all on solo practice hasn't
connected the data it's just
computerized it and that does and that's
not enough so people need to have a
vision for what you can actually do with
it there are some people who are kind of
zealots and saying let's get all the
data on the computer and that's a good
first step as long as it's a first step
but if it's a final step it's a
completely inadequate and incredibly
expensive final step and the other thing
is typically when the doctor has worked
for the same piece of paper for 30 years
they know that piece of paper really
well I can put all note here a little
longer to do there and they've got a
night clerk if they're going to a
computer screen now they have to learn a
whole different interaction they have to
you know I just think about when you
change from you know blackberry to an
iphone whatever I mean you have to go
through all this learning curve if you
go through the learning curve to go from
paper to electronic and you get nothing
out of it except it slowed you down well
first you're not going to do it I mean
when you one of things I talk about in
the book is you all view information for
all the patients all the time is really
important but the second thing is make
the right thing easy to do and that's
really important you got to make the
right thing easy to do and whoever is
writing in if you make the right thing
easy to do as a result of the
computerization doctors will go there
and the care system will go there and if
you don't make the right thing easy to
do then the barriers to moving in that
direction will be insurmountable now
another user at cat naugle asks what's
the biggest tech breakthrough in
healthcare on the horizon that's
exciting you and your peers you know is
there something that is going to perhaps
make this process even easier still both
to integrate and to actually use I think
a couple of things are exciting it i
think the ability to take a DNA database
and figure out on bond cholesterol
reduction drugs we know that the drugs
worked really well on a portion of the
population and we know they don't work
so well on another portion of the
population but we don't know why they
work in some we don't know why they
don't work in others if we could do a
DNA analysis and figure out which
patients benefit from zocor and make
sure those patients get zocor then we've
got a very different much more effective
care delivery world so I think the
ability to personalize care around the
patient based on DNA is really exciting
and I think the research that will
follow from it is really exciting and I
think the connectivity issue the ability
to get to deliver care remotely to have
there's a shortage of primary care on
the one hand and there's logistical
issues relative to specialty care on the
other hand and if you can resolve the
logistical issues by doing many of the
things virtually and if you can solve
the primary care issues by reaching out
into a broader continuum and then having
the care delivery upfront delivered some
cases by nurse practitioners who have a
close ally who is a primary care
physician who is completely supported by
an infrastructure of specialists the
combination of that sort of a tiered
system is going to be a more effective
more efficient better use of energy more
patient responsive sort of care delivery
system than much of what we have now so
I think there's some opportunities to
re-engineer care delivery as well as to
personalize care and get cure right and
we just have a couple of minutes left so
i figured i would say way to the
million-dollar question which actually
was submitted by another user at small
biz trends which is basically you know
he writes will things get better under
the health care proposals being floated
in Congress right now or will the
proposals increase bureaucracy paperwork
and cost and i'll add to that do you see
the proposed these proposals advancing
the vision that you have laid out or is
this step in the direction as thing
they're headed it can be it can be there
there are some things in the bills that
are directionally correct they really do
want to have database connectivity
there's kind of a pointer in that
direction the details of how to do that
the are not fleshed out so the ability
to figure out how do we actually create
connectivity isn't there and there's
enough resistance to connectivity that I
can imagine a scenario where five years
from now we spend an awful lot of money
on IT and haven't connected anybody and
I can also imagine a scenario where five
years from now we spend a lot of money
and IT and we've connected everybody now
you can you can get to either outcome
from here and part of its going to be
the steerage part of its going to be
Secretary Sebelius who in these bills is
given us all kinds of accountability for
doing pieces of this work which i think
is a good thing to do rather than trying
to design all the pieces of it pointed
in a direction and assign someone and if
if she has the kind of years that I
really hope she has care could be a lot
better in America on the other hand
there enough people resisting change and
happy enough for the status quo that we
could also run up against roadblocks and
end up not making the progress so we
need to cover everyone we really do need
to cover everyone every other country in
the world every other industrialized
country covers all of their citizens
we're the only outlier and we really
need to cover everyone because there are
some really serious health conditions
that we can fix until everybody has
coverage I mean husband is one of them
all the kids need coverage so we've got
continuity of care and then they need to
be in a database so we can track the
care and we can follow up in the care
and if you have that kind of a vision
for where we're going you can get there
the bills would allow for that but it's
going to take execution on the back end
George I want to thank you so much for
joining us tremendous our really
communicated powerfully how technology
can radically reshape this
the system and take us to another higher
level of care for everybody I want to
thank everybody in our audience online
for joining us today again I'm Peter
Hopkins president and co-founder a big
thing thanks so much